peut-on envisager un arbitrage de
football entièrement automatisé depuis
plusieurs années l'arbitrage du football
s'est beaucoup modernisé en exploitant
des nouvelles technologies de
l'information notamment la Gold line
technologie qui permet de savoir si le
ballon a franchi la ligne de but ou non
également dans le cas de la règle du
horsjeu dont les lignes sont maintenant
tracées à l'aide de nombreuses caméras
et d'algorithmes ok mais ça ça semble
être des applications facile des
technologies de l'information à
l'arbitrage du football après tout dans
ces deux cas tout ce joue exclusivement
sur un problème d'information le ballon
a-t-il franchi la ligne et l'attaquant
était-il devant le dernier défenseur au
moment de la passe de son coéquipier ou
non mais intuitivement on pourrait se
dire que l'arbitrage du football recè
une dose de subjectivité dès lors qu'il
s'agit de juger si une main est licite
ou non ou si une faute doit être sifflée
ou non dès lors la simple notion
d'information semble insuffisante il
semble nécessaire d'y ajouter une dose
de jugement humain ce qui pourrait
suggérer que l'IA n'est pas applicable à
ces cas et donc à l'arbitrage général du
football mais est-ce vraiment le cas la
subjectivité est-elle suffisante pour
rejeter l'usage des
IA pour qu'un algorithme applique les
lois du football on pourrait-être tenter
de lui faire simplement lire les lois du
football et de faire en sorte que
l'algorithme respecte ses lois à la
lettre mais donc comment ces lois
définissent-elles les fautes qui
donneent lieu à un coup franc direct par
exemple et bien on peut les lire
puisqu'elles sont rendues publiquement
accessibles par le Conseil international
du football association ou ifab en
anglais je cite la loi 12.1 en
particulier un coup franc direct est
accord si de la vie de l'arbitre un
joueur commet l'une des fautes suivantes
de manière imprudente inconsidérée ou
violente charge un adversaire saute sur
un adversaire donne ou essaie de donner
un coup de pied à l'adversaire bouscule
l'adversaire frappe ou essaie de frapper
un adversaire y compris un coup de boule
tacle un adversaire ou lui dispute le
ballon fait ou essaie de faire trébucher
un advers adversaire clairement ces lois
sont difficiles à encoder dans un
algorithme en premier lieu l'expression
l'avis de l'arbitre est explicitement
utilisée autrement dit selon l'IFAB la
décision revient avant tout à une
interprétation par le corps arbitral
d'ailleurs cela peut paraître fort
insatisfaisant si l'avis de l'arbitre va
à l'encontre de celui de tous les
observateurs et sachant que l'arbitre
peut-être corrompu par la pression du
public ou des avances financière comme
cela a été le cas dans le passé est-ce
vraiment la vie d'un arbitre humain
imparfait et corruptible qui doit faire
fois mais surtout la loi utilise des
critères qui sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à modéliser et à trancher que
ceux qui sont utilisés pour déterminer
s'il y a but en partic si le ballon a
franchi la ligne de but ou si un joueur
est en position de hors jeu en effet on
trouve dans la loi des mots comme
imprudente inconsidéré et violente
sachant que le football reste un sport
de contact où les charges et les
bouscules sont en fait souvent licite
comment tracer la frontière entre les
interventions de la sorte qui sont
considérées de celle qui serait
inconsidéré comment un algorithme est
censé considérer le mot considéré
htmema en fait la manière dont les
arbitres et les professionnels et les
amateurs de football ont appris à
distinguer les actions de jeu qui sont
des fautes de celles qui ne sont pas des
fautes ça repose bien plus sur la
jurisprudence que sur des lois déjà
existante écrite autrement dit à force
de regarder des matchs de football et en
particulier des arbitres arbitrer des
matchs de football on a fini par
apprendre à reconnaître les actions où
la plupart des arbitres siffleraient et
à les distinguer des actions où les
arbitres ne sifflent généralement pas et
c'est certainement bien plus cet
apprentissage par expérience qui nous a
permis de définir dans nos tête ce qui
constitue une action sanctionnable par
un coup franc direct comme finalement
beaucoup de choses dans notre quotidien
nous avons appris ce qui constitue une
faute de jeu à partir d'un grand nombre
d'exemples beaucoup plus qu'à l'aide
d'une une définition rigoureuse que l'on
appliquerait à la lettre un peu comme
les sens des mots courants sont bien
plus définis par leur usage que par une
définition imposée par un dictionnaire
d'ailleurs pour justifier qu'une action
de jeu aurait dû ou n'aurait pas dû être
sifflée plutôt que de lire la loi les
commentateurs sportifs vont surtout
s'appuyer sur des actions de jeu
similaires qui dans le passé ont été
jugées différemment autrement dit leur
argument exploitent davantage la
jurisprudence que la loi mais donc par
conséquent si on veut que quiconque
humain ou machine sache arbitrer dans le
sens où si on veut qu'ils arbitrent
comme la plupart des observateurs s'y
attendent il va falloir que l'entité
arbitrale regarde d'abord beaucoup de
football et apprenne ce qui dans les
actions de football qui ont été joué
dans le passé rend les actions
sifflables ou non et bien ça c'est
exactement ce que les algorithmes
modernes font les algorithmes dit
d'apprentissage ou de machine learning
en anglais consiste précisément à
généraliser des données observées et
comme il y a des kilomètres de bande de
vidéos de football avec des sifflés
d'arbitres et des non sifflés d'arbitres
il semble y avoir largement de quoi
concevoir des algorithmes qui
apprendront ce qui fait qu'une action
est généralement sifflable ou non et
c'est pour ça que je m'attends à ce que
dans les années à venir voire dans les
mois à venir l'arbitrage pourra être
entièrement automatisable qui plus est
contrairement à l'arbitrage humain
l'arbitre algorithmique pourra exploiter
tous les angles de vue de toutes les
caméras pour prendre sa décision et
contrairement à l'arbitrage assist par
la vidéo la décision de l'arbitrage
algorithmique pourrait être rendue en
une fraction de secondes plutôt qu'en
quelques minutes et ça pour le spectacle
ce sera beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mieux
mais donc sachant tout ce que j'ai dit
l'arbitrage algorithmique serait-il
vraiment pour demain peut-on envisager
qu'une nia prenne les commandes des
matchs de
football et bien même le jour où lia
paraîtra prendre des décisions
raisonnables dans une démonstration
faite par l'entreprise qui développe
cette IA il faudra certainement que
celle-ci soit auditée testée et
décortiquée par plusieurs entités
indépendantes pour que toutes les
parties prenantes du football acceptent
qu'ell soit déployé après tout qui nous
dit que lia n'a pas un biais
systématique en faveur de certaines
équipes quand on sait à quel point le
football italien était sous l'emprise de
la corruption notamment comme cela a été
révélé dans l'affaire calcho poly n'y
a-t-il pas un risque que en généralisant
le passé on généralise aussi un arbitre
favorable à des équipes comme la
Juventus ou le Milan AC et cuide des
suspicions modernes par exemple
concernant le FC Barcelone pour contrer
les risques de biè systématique
volontaire ou involontaire il peut-être
utile d'exploiter le voile d'ignorance
du philosophe John HES autrement dit
pour juger si une action de jeu est une
faute ou non il faudrait idéalement que
ce jugement soit le même quel que soient
les deux équipes qui se sont opposées ou
dit autrement la décision de siffler
faute ne doit pas dépendre de la couleur
des maillots du potentiel fautif et de
la potentielle victime et bien ce voile
d'ignorance pourrait être être
explicitement encodé dans l'entraînement
de l'IA arbitre après avoir appris des
cas passés C Ia pourrait suivre une
phase d'entraînement additionnel où on
lui apprend à fournir les mêmes
jugements lorsqu'on lui fournit les
mêmes images mais avec des couleurs de
maillot modifié voire avec des visages
et des morphologies de joueurs modifiés
oui carlia pourrait avoir appris des
choses plus subtiles comme on ne cifle
pas les fautes sur Messi par exemple
bref avant tout déploiement massif le
problème des biiaias doit absolument
être traité avec grand soin ceci étant
dit il ne me semble pas insurmontable si
vraiment on y met le moyen en fait le
vrai problème des arbitres de football
me semble être
ailleurs sachant à quel point la FIFA
est proche de dictatur comme le Qatar et
l'Arabie Saoudite et sachant à quel
point ces pays investissent dans le
cybercrim il faudrait certainement avoir
un œil constant sur les as arbitres et
vérifier qu'ell se comporte de manière
satisfaisante et non hacké ou bac doré
par des entités malveillantes en fait
l'enjeu fondamental pour que les a
d'arbitrage de football soit éthique et
sécurisé me semble résider avant tout
dans leur gouvernance qui pourra auditer
ces Ia qui auditera les auditeurs ce
groupe d'auditeurs sera-t-il lui-même
résilient à la corruption à quell
données à propos des za auront-ils accès
et surtout s'il détecte des
comportements indésirables des IA comme
un biais systématique en faveur d'une
équipe de quel recours disposeront-ils
pour modifier le comportement des IA et
si l'on voit tous que l'IA a commis une
erreur grossière comment pourra-t-on
corriger l'IA et comment pourra-t-on
vérifier que la correction qu'on aura
demandé aura bien été faite et sera
conservée j'ai envie de dire que tant
que des réponses satisfaisantes n'auront
pas été fournies à ces questions le
déploiement d'IA arbitre de football me
semble hautement indésirable même si la
possibilité de concevoir des arbitres de
football de niveau surhumain est avérée
et bien sûr si je vous parle de football
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas que pour vous
parler de football les enjeux dont je
parle ici ne sont bien sûr pas
restreints aux arbitres de football en
fait l'arbitre arbitrage de football
reste un enjeu bien moindre que
l'arbitrage entre la recommandation de
différents contenus informationnels à
des milliards d'utilisateurs dont les
IAS de TikTok Youtube et Twitter ont le
monopole malgré l'absence de tout audit
externe ni même la possibilité pour les
régulateurs d'analyser correctement ces
Ia faute d'accès au code sources et
surtout aux données d'entraînement ou de
comportement de ces Ia grandeur nature
et surtout malgré les très nombreuses
données parcellaires mais déjà
extrêmement compromettantes auxquelles
les chercheurs et les journalistes
indépendants ont pu avoir accès comme
les Facebook phases qui manquent un
changement de Lia de Facebook de 2018 a
conduit à la radicalisation de médias en
quête de vue pour leur survie économique
avec des conséquences aussi gravissimes
que le déclin des démocraties et la
montée de l'autoritarisme à travers le
monde bref toute préoccupation qui vous
semble raisonnable pour la validation du
nia arbitre de football devrait vous
paraître beaucoup plus critique encore
pour les IA arbitres de l'information et
la situation actuelle où ces arbitres de
l'information sont hors de contrôle
devrait vous paraître absolument
inacceptable de manière plus générale
nos concitoyens et nos sociétés font
beaucoup trop confiance au servicees de
géant du numérique qui ne mérit
certainement pas un tel niveau de
confiance je ne peux que vous encourager
à questionner vos fournisseurs de
services informatiques et à envisager
des alternatives plus éthiques sécurisé
et souveraines et justement le sponsor
de cette vidéo infomaniaque est un
fournisseur de service cloud qui
s'appuie sur une souveraineté et une
éthique très supérieure à celle des
concurrents américains qui à cause du
Patriot Act se doivent de partager vos
données avec les autorités américaines
si celles-ci l'exigent autrement dit ces
concurrents américains sont
officiellement facilement corruptibles à
contrario infomaniaque fait un effort
majeur pour tout développer de manière
souveraine avec des collaborateurs
uniquement en Suisse vous pouvez
profiter gratuitement d'une adresse
email gratuite avec kadrive qui respecte
votre vie privée à l'adresse ethque.com
et je vous recommande aussi vivement
d'utiliser leur service gratuit Suiss
transfer pour partager vos gros fichiers
chaque vidéo où je les promux ce que je
fais avec avec plaisir infomaniaque
reverse un don à l'association tournesol
Merci beaucoup à eux pour ce
partenariat plus généralement il me
semble que dans le cas du déploiement
d'une nia pour arbitrer le football tous
les entraîneurs les joueurs les
commentateurs et les supporters de
football serait unanime pour l'exigence
d'une présomption de nonconformité de C
Ia qui nous dit que les propriétaires
émiratis de Manchester City les
propriétaires saouiens de Newcastle ou
les propriétaires qataris du
parisint-germain n'ont pas inclu des B
acteur dans l'IA pour que cellees-ci
siffle plus systématiquement des
pénalties lors des actions litigieuses
et confuses qui favorisent ces équipes
lorsqu'elles en ont un besoin critique
cela m'étonnerait ainsi très fortement
qu'unea arbitre de football soit
autorisé à la commercialisation et à
l'utilisation pour les match de football
si en amont il n'y avait pas eu
suffisamment de procédures d'évaluation
de l'éthique et de la sécurité d'une
telle Ia mais alors pourquoi en
serait-il autrement des autres a
beaucoup plus sophistiqué et
géopolitiquement influentes qui ont déjà
envahi les réseaux r sociaux qu'il
s'agisse de chat GPT ou de liad de
recommandation de TikTok comment en
est-on venu à faire confiance à des
outils du numérique qui si elles étaient
appliquées au football soulèverait
probablement des levées de boucliers
très légitimes la vraie différence avec
les avions c'est que s'il y a un crash
tout le monde peut le voir tout le monde
peut s'en inquiéter tout le monde peut
consevoir à quel point c'est dramatique
et cetera on a l'impression que le crash
de l'intelligence artificielle on peut
pas le voir on sait pas à quoi ça
ressemblerait on sait même pas si c'est
dramatique est-ce qu'il y aurait des
flammes est-ce qu'il y aurait des morts
ce serait quoi c'est quoi le crash de
l'intelligence artificielle ouais B
alors si si on regarde en terme de de
conséquence alors vraiment
l'intelligence artificielle c'est c'est
avant tout du traitement de
l'information c'est ça ça produit
l'information ça traite deinformation ça
gère dans l'information et si on regarde
les conséquences de plus plus
globalement l'industrie de l'information
des technologies de l'information quand
il Appell on se rend compte qu'il y a
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de conséquences
donc un crash ça peut être un génocide
donc il y a eu le cas du génocide des
roingas au myanemark qui a été reconnu
par Amnesty internationale et
l'Organisation des Nations Unies avec le
rôle notamment comp de l'algorithme de
Facebook qui amplifia les appels à la
haine au meurtre VO voir au génocide et
dans le cas dans dans les démocratie bon
on l'observe bà il y a eu les éutes du
capital aux États-Unis avec beaucoup de
désinformation dans tous les sens et
puis même en Suisse on l'observe avec
des choses comme de la diffamation qui a
été faite récemment envers par bincha
donc le chatpter utilisé par Microsoft
Bing Search envers des politiciens
Suisse notamment Balthazar gletly et
également on observe également une
amplification de de la haine on l'a
beaucoup vu notamment dans les les
débats autour de la vaccination et que
faudrait-il pour concevoir des outils
numériques vraiment dignes de confiance
qui notamment ne seraient pas facilement
corruptible par des entités
malveillantes et bien cette dernière
question c'est précisément le grand défi
que s'est fixé l'association tournesol
notre organisation à but non lucratif
donc je suis le président et absolument
pas un salarié depuis maintenant plus de
3 ans nous avons réuni des expertises en
mathématique en informatique en
philosophie et en sociologie entre
autres pour concevoir une plateforme
Open Source de gouvernance démocratique
sécurisée des IA de recommandation et si
l'on s'est donc intéressé surtout aux
arbitres de l'information nul doute que
nombre des outils que nous avons
développés sont en fait aussi
applicables à l'arbitrage du football
ceci étant dit il nous reste beaucoup de
chemins à effectuer pour que la
gouvernance algorithmique de tournesol
soit vraiment satisfaisante pour cela
nous avons besoin de nombreuses formes
d'aide de vos évaluations de la
recommandabilit de divers contenus à des
dons financiers pour nous permettre de
garder notre excellent employé en
passant par des contributions à la code
base aux mathématiques des algorithmes
de tournesol ou encore à la simple
promotion de la plateforme pour toute
l'aide que vous pourrez nous fournir
nous tenons à exprimer d'ors et déjà
notre extrême gratitude ce n'est qu'à la
suite d'une mobilisation générale et de
progrès majeurs dans la sécurité
l'éthique et la gouvernance des IA que
je pourrais en venir un jour à
recommander un arbitrage entièrement par
les IA que ce soit du football ou de
l'information